Film Courage: Looking at your IMDB [page]
you have 31 or so producing credits.
I’m sure there are going to be more by the
time of this video releases.
Which production taught you the most?
Passionflix co-founder Tosca Musk: Wow!
Well, I learned a lot on so many of the different
movies that I’ve done, so it depends on
what did I learn?
I’ve made a lot of movies and I think that
the ones that have taught me the most are
I made a movie called HAVENHURST (that one
taught me a lot).
It was a horror to me, it was horror film.
It was very difficult and I realize there
are many things that I will not do again,
so that’s a great thing to learn.
Great movie, the movie ultimately ended up
being very good, but the experience for me
as a producer was not a great one.
The things that I’ve learned the most, I
mean I’ve made a lot of movies.
I think ultimately the best lesson that I’ve
learned which is from making the Passionflix
movies is that I need to enjoy the experience
from start to finish because it is very hard
to make a movie and it costs a lot of money.
And if you’re not enjoying it, then there
is no reason to do it.
So I learned that from making these movies
prior to this (prior to Passionflix) realizing
that (from hindsight) I did not enjoy making
a lot of those movies and I do enjoy making
the Passionflix movies.
They’re fulfilling, they make me happy,
I can’t wait to make the next one.
Whereas prior to that I was not enjoying them,
it was more of a job.
Not to say they were bad experiences, I made
some great movies and I really enjoyed the
people and fortunately now with Passionflix
I get to bring so many of those people on
to my productions.
But sometimes when you are working for other
people and you’re getting notes from them,
they’re not necessarily the notes that I
would probably…how can I say this?
Sometimes their interpretation of what the
movie should be is not my interpretation of
what the movie should be and that is filmmaking.
I mean that’s the creative process.
I don’t necessarily want to show women in
a certain light and so I didn’t enjoy that
specific film.
And now I get to show a woman in the light
that I like to show them, so it makes me happy.
I just like to have positive experiences in
film, I think that’s the important thing.
The Tiki Bar TV which was a podcast that I
did (a video podcast that I did) was a perfect
example of making something and really enjoying
it every single time you made it because it
was funny and the people were great and so
now I get to do that again.
Please do come to one of our sets when we
make the next one.
We are laughing and joking and having the
best time.
The crew that I have on all of my movies are
almost the same crew for the last year.
They just come, they transplant back, they
all come to my new sets because we have great
experiences and it’s just so much fun.
Film Courage: Environment is so important.
Tosca Musk: Environment is vital.
Especially it’s high-pressure, it’s time-sensitive,
and you have to be creative within these confines.
And we don’t have the luxury (yet) of being
able to say “Oh, we’ll just do it tomorrow.
We’ll just pick it up and let’s just lengthen
the time frame of this movie.”
We need to shoot these movies in 15, 16 days
and we need to get them out and we have fans
that we release the movie on one day, the
next day they say “Where’s the next movie?”
It takes 5 months to make a movie at minimum!
And so we are trying very hard to get them
out as quickly as possible.
So we need to make the experience fun and
we need to make sure that we are all in this
positive, creative environment so that we
can create the best movie.
Film Courage: Sure and too if you are doing
sensitive scenes with the actors to have it
where you feel safe [on set].
That’s what I was saying [earlier], I felt
that when I watched the [Passionflix] behind
the scenes footage, just kind of a feeling
of being safe.
Tosca Musk: Thank you!
Yeah, it’s very important that the actors
are comfortable on our set and my crew is
extremely respectful and every single time
we come to any of these scenes, I have a conversation
with my actors, I need to make sure that they
are comfortable.
We will rehearse everything, we will then
move forward with more.
The sets are closed and we’re constantly
talking about where a hand should be, what
it should be.
This is not just willy-nilly “Go ahead and
try things!”
We’re very specific on where the camera
is, what we’ll do, where we are following
hands and what I want those hands to do.
And I have to make sure that both my male
and female actors feel comfortable with what
I need to portray.